this is a production of Cornell
University
great thank you thanks yeah thank you
sorry
um it's a great pleasure to be here to
share well I I don't feel actually I'm
coming home actually because I used to
be in section of horticulture right so
um it's a really great pleasure to share
a song of or listen to researches on on
you know sort of broccoli uh not all you
can see actually I just share part of a
research on progress and the title you
can see actually molecular mechanisms of
Parental response to warmer temperature
so I was sort of struggling whether to
use let me see whether I could have my
no pointer I tried to use a pointer uh
the warmer actually or warming
temperature so it's uh I have been it
works I think so okay that's great thank
you thank you very much
yeah okay so I have been debating
actually whether you're swarming at the
replicating idea or carrying actually
the warming temperature then I change it
to five last minute I changed to warmer
temperature but you know essentially
saying actually speaking of a warming
temperature where immediately they
realize huh why doesn't
um the global warming okay so you will
see actually global warming he said well
global warming generally refers to you
know certain maybe 50 years or whatever
actually period the type of temperature
increase so you can see here it's barely
uh one or two degrees difference so what
what matters right especially you know
this is a sort of introductory slides
you will see actually this is global
warming uh uh sort of diagram and a
little bit of exaggerated perhaps but
that being said you will see actually
this is a warming really matters
um here is actually uh one week ago
actually just published when there will
be strong stratospheric warming actually
events happens then will cause actually
polar vortex then polar vortex actually
you know serious uh sort of Chopper
sphere temperature will be dramatically
changed actually certain area will be
surely much much warmer than it used to
be and of course sometimes certain area
will be cooler than it used to be okay
so the warming the temperature
fluctuation is real is dramatic so
warming really matters as a matter of
fact not simply just one or two
temperature two degree differences
so the well Stories the polar you know
bear because of the global warming and
the first horror Bill migrates to land
area
and as you can see here and then
actually well the land actually will
brown bear actually habitats and then
when of course when hiring sorry what's
happened you guys know that is actually
have baby here okay called The Polar
Polar Bear okay now why now this is
actually lost
yeah November 17 News actually it's
recently news they use this as an
example actually to show global warming
but I use a separate you know sort of in
reverse
uh sort of Direction and that is why the
warming may be a good thing for this new
baby right so this is but a warm in
general you more harm than beneficial
okay this is a December 6th Corner
Chronicle News so warming work lead to
that sort of New York upstate New Yorker
sort of lakes oxygen content such as
dramatically
reduced okay now uh this is oxygen in
Lake but in terms of the warming on
plants so the warming effect on plants
could accelerate plants uh develop
growth and development or actual delay
the growth and development okay
and in terms of
the effect on on vegetative growth it
will generally warming will promote a
cellular elongation
and which will lead to the Waco stains
or Patriots
okay so weaker plants you can see here
but the warming temperature will have
more profound impact on reproductive
growth
as you can see here actually it will
promote earlier flowing a transition to
floor could be earlier and significantly
reduced pollen production
and also actually pollen germination
with significant in heptopore
ingermination and fertilization thus
actually significantly reduce the CD
yield okay so
um
now uh in terms of today I said use
progress example you know Tom Thomas I
know Thomas is online uh Thomas Buchman
actually did the work actually years ago
and the higher temperature okay on the
broccoli so we're talking about broccoli
today you can see in Greenhouse or in
field in green Halls so both of high
temperature you know this field about 30
degrees Celsius and in Greenhouse about
35 degree uh CSS you can see here but
will cause actually only even appearance
of head in a broker head or actually is
severely injured head
predominantly small but you know sort of
quantitatively quantity and the quality
will be significantly impact okay high
temperature
and uh
another example that was Galaxy actually
uh uh broccoli but in terms of green
Harmony uh uh broccoli you can see here
uh six at January 16th degree uh
produced such a normal broccoli head we
are consuming and then it will grow at
28 degrees Celsius you see the produce
actually cauliflower-like code
22 degree you will see produce
intermediate uh hate a cloud that would
call the code okay now this was work was
done actually by also Thomas buchman's
lab actually was graduate student former
graduate student Denise uh the cross
actually uh who actually used to work in
my lab as a matter of fact uh to to
dissect the molecular uh mechanisms
underlying this sort of change
so uh what the Denise did actually that
calling actually
uh I think she spent a one uh
halfway or one year in my lab actually
to provide uh sort of this flower
identity genes
um during letter brokerage development
so try to see what's going on with
relate to that and to be honest with you
at that time I was very critical
regarding this work I thought this work
is just
reveal the underlying molecular
mechanisms you just use you test
actually watching here of course this
Gene compared with this way G expressed
hair of course wouldn't Express that
right so you provide it really didn't
mean too much so I was very critical and
Denise was really unhappy actually about
this so I'm sorry actually to do this
but that was the fact Okay so and
um uh I have I give her her time
actually during the difference because I
was sit on her Caesar's defense too and
uh
Denise you know as I said actually
provide his PCR analyzes different gene
expression at the different stages of
those actually sort of uh
a broker head or abnormal broker ahead
now you can imagine as you can see
actually certain Gene not takes Express
here of course not to express there
right so it's really not so insightful
okay
um
so uh
no this is a really good actually uh uh
review uh I mean uh illustration of that
uh about for our development and the
regulatory genes involved in this one as
you can see here different genes a
pillar two you know those sort of Aging
ABC in the model you guys perhaps know
actually right thing and what's happened
actually you see actually this stage is
sort of in forces marriage thing
actually this cauliflower so-called IM
okay that's crawl development at this
stage is in fluorescence mirrors at 16
degrees that's equivalent to that broker
development you can see here okay so I
am I am later we were frequently use the
stone
and this stage is a intermediate stage
equivalent to actually 22 degree okay
that's that's for for our primordial
stage okay that's what the nature of
that intermediate occurred
and uh for our parts code called the FB
stage as you can see that's what the
broccoli were we are consuming right
that's water on share on the grocery
store you will see actually that's FB
stage so you will see IM stage FB stage
and the fpfp stage FB stage it's a
different temperature equivalent to this
development as I said actually why I was
so critical because let's say if you
going to Pro
profiling the expression of AP strategy
of course you know if we stop here
there's no expression there at all okay
so you you sample the sample and it says
oh there's no AP expression here but the
expression here so what's happening of
course there shouldn't have any
expression right so that's why I was
said not so uh inside for informative
actually so that's why what I mean
actually that's was I was so critical
okay so but again actually this is the
terminology you can see 16 degree at
least here so you know what you can see
very clearly 16 degree iron stage that's
Corey flow uh measure stem actually like
in forces mirrors then that's called
polyphrololike code okay so IM Stitch
then intermediate is really far
development stopped at the FB FPS FP
stage okay then what's that's what we
are talking about actually what we are
eating actually at the FB stage
now uh back to this one actually I I
frequently have been asked to say hey uh
when I'm in a media interviewed me
actually says hey why are you getting to
this project
so uh that wasn't really let you
actually Professor actually leaving Chen
from chichang University and she visited
my lab as a rescue scholar in early 2010
times actually and then she returned to
to chichang University
and uh uh 2017 I was invited to visit
chachang University then we discussed
about a potential collaborations
okay so one of collaboration we
initiated is this work
uh demacylation again at immaculation in
leaf sentences because as I said
actually a doctor leaving Chang
is an expert actually on sale graphic
and its Associated app genetic uh sort
of mechanism especially DNA macellations
okay so I thought okay I work on
sentences you are good at sort of
massillation and let's work together
about this G so this was published uh
sort of in molecular plants yes back
and then another actually uh
collaboration work was sort of this
today's topic that's the mechanisms
underlying temperature induced
reproductive growth in broccoli and uh
so I thought you know this is really
interesting
phenotype and but unfortunately
molecular mechanism is not understood so
I sort of now of course we have another
project I didn't list here that's
massive Arizona
sort of achieving uh transfer and that's
a very exciting story actually well
drafting that the manuscript but this is
back to this one so we are working on
this sort of two days project that's how
I get into this project okay now back to
this slides I just showed you and in
order to investigate into this one so we
decided to add additional stage that's
the transition stage okay from
vegetative girls to reproductive growth
it's a USC VR called a vegetative to
reproductive growth and if Hereafter you
will frequently see
the terminology VR I am
FP and FB okay so don't get confused I'm
not going to spell out later but this is
a different stage of for our development
although this is from our devices but
it's pretty much the same as in
brokering okay so remember this is
actually this terminology I will not
repeat this terminology
so in order to do that you know as I
said
so this is we first we need to repeat
whether this is a phenotype actually
shows up you can see this is surely okay
so this is a VR stage okay uh 16 degree
at 22 degree 28 degrees you see this is
28 degrees will be arrested or stopped
throughout development stopped or at the
IM stage enforce and similar State
stages okay so regardless how many days
you just grow you just stop at this
stage produce cauliflower like code
22 degree you know that's intermediate
then six Centigrade of course that's the
brokery uh head you see okay now at that
time actually I thought why is it
collaboration with her actually about
apart I use a sort of epigenetic
mechanism involved the GM isolation
because I saw at that point I told her I
said my gut feeling sometimes gut
feeling is not necessarily true but in
this case I better write I told her I
said epigenetic mechanisms involved
either sort of chromating modification
that's acetylation or actually being a
methylation
okay so actually are you in lined up
with my one of my former projects now
actually a professor at the King
University
um who work on chromating actually are
uh uh more modification escalation of
those proteins
so and uh then another mechanism I said
it's vacillation most likely involving
mechanisms so the tester mechanism
and use
uh DNA Mac oscillation inhibitor okay
actually now this is the water we treat
with water you can see 24 days 31 days
all remains 20 28 degrees this is a 28
degree remains as Corey flow like cold
okay that's that's the same time however
if we exactly say at the 28 degree no
that's 28 degrees right it's just the
stopped at this influence mirror stick
but if we treat with DNA me acceleration
inhibitor you will see actually this is
developed sort of intermediate and then
a broker uh paid
right so yeah
even at the 28th degree were you seeing
a massillation inhibitor so this is
actually for all develop as if walk
around at a 16 degree
right so that means no before I get your
conclusion so it's about the DNA
methylation being a methylation is
generally have takes place actually on
the cytosine C then macalated here as
you can see here right in the DNA
okay so the methylated and uh so under
the enzymatica sort of methylation
muscle is actually at the very later
stage of the mechanism actually where we
need to study later where I will get
back to this mechanism
and of course mechanism there were a few
DNA methylation patterns energy it was
CG padding are capacitated the C and chg
will be macylated in a h stand for could
be anything ATC okay so the H or in the
context of chhh
so that will be you know see massillated
but HH could be any of this all right so
I will refer to this uh a sort of
methylation pattern in the context when
I say the in context of CG or in context
of chg or chh so you were just you know
part of sort of uh C would that will be
massilling okay
now that uh
five for you know
macylation inhibitor is in here so n of
course here this is carbon here right
this is another nitrogen of course
there's no way this could be methylated
to other muscle groups right so that's
the whole that's a mechanism of uh for
uh for DNA methylation inhibitors
hop back to this way so you can see here
we're already showed actually I already
showed that during a methylation hipster
just eliminates the temperature induced
actually for cessation or unrest right
developed normally so the conclusion is
very very clear that is DNM isolation is
involved in the warming temperature
induced change of broker head to
cauliflower light code right so if you
guys have any problem with this
conclusion
okay so once we know that DNM
oscillation is involved then you know
again actually my my gut feeling was
right and so then the next of course is
to to to test to investigate the global
uh sort of whole genome by sulfate uh uh
sequence method to measure the whole
genus during the methylation profiles
okay so now uh being this mechanism is
called wgbs called A bisoffic sequence
it's really actually biosulphate were
converting C to U then U will be can see
when sequenced okay but if macellated CE
will be remain as C so by sequence this
one so then you will take you will be
able to know which one is macylated
which way is not masculated okay that's
the principle of of this
um macylation
so in order to do that so with you know
this is I showed you so we decide to
harvest the sampling okay the water
sampling stage you would decide to
harvest this is different this is
certain stage actually we harvest the
samples 28 degree at iron stage and
because there's no way you can Hive it's
the same thing like you're meaningless
right so there will be actually uh two
samples from for DNA methylation Global
you know by sulfate methylation purpose
so the two replicates not soil replicas
tulip because it's so expensive and then
at the same time I will get back to this
one where at the same time we harvest
the three biological replicates that
means we'll actually have a psori
transcriptos so you know it will work
for each point we have two
mushrooms and stray transcriptions okay
for each stage at the same same sample
same stage we Harvest
now get back to actually continue to
discuss about the methylone
so muscle you know where all those data
we are not going to go over but you will
see actually the global Dynamic changes
you will see at 28 degree USC
methylation into in the contacts or CT
context I say the CG contacts chg and
chhh contact so that's what the
previously I I told you that sort of if
I see any of them you see the
massillation levels are higher than
lower temperature right so uh in a you
know sort of with global change actually
we're not going to go over and but what
I want to show you show your attention
to is the gene promoter regime so the
certain genes and the promoteraging and
the three pong actually uh on
translating so the promoter region you
can see here
huh
does not work anymore
oh it's here okay so you can see
actually this is 28 degree okay the high
temperature then my solution level
higher then
then 22 degrees then then actually 60
degree that's normal produce so the
macylation level or change is actually
really actually matters now this is a CH
context okay this chg contacts sensing
actually although the chhh contacts
really doesn't matter too much because I
didn't see significant increase
okay the pro model ranging you see the
pro model region
um are really in vacillation level
higher than actually
and uh
so of course there's a different stage
of this mess along we're already
established we need you need to what you
need to do of course by informatics just
the different comparison okay in order
to compare you can see you can imagine
we performed all various actually uh
sort of analysis you know VR stage
whatever stages you see the macellation
pattern change so and so forth 22 degree
16 degree okay so uh because of the time
I'm not going to go over but to simplify
to this presentation I will draw your
attention mainly actually focus on the
analysis comparison of this transcript
on this and here and here and this
comparison of this one in order to get
the genes related to this you know
arrest at this stage for uh for genes
required for Im so we'll analyze
actually this group of analyzes okay so
to simplify this but
no uh
I say or I say that you know macellation
changes raging so that's terminology
called the differentially methylated
religion called EMR okay so DMR DMR
what's the thing of work sometimes where
you use the hypermecillation for example
normal cell cancer cellphone you can see
here this cancels in this cancer cell
this is the cancer cell this DNA is a
highly macylated compared with normal
then we call this region is a highly
metallic vice versa this is a sort of a
hypo message
and of course could be both High versus
low you know those first High episode of
course you know that's irrelevant right
so we are not going to pay attention to
those genes but just managing the
isolation changes okay so so first of
all we need to identify those
differential muscle regions
a case called emrs
and uh
so compare 28 degree versus 60 degree we
have a VR stage you see actually
271 sort of in CG context okay CG
context you see actually a
differentially message
and you know we are not going to go over
you know the status but you can see
there's various state of macellation
certain raging change actually of hyper
methylated or high pore Nestle okay and
hypothematology which is a different
comparison I saw like they mentioned to
you uh 30
so uh based on this actually we have
sort of at the same time we already
identify this differentiated method
um our regions certain numbers of this
one so I will leave this when move to
another actually a topic related topic
that's actually as I already mentioned
we also have three transcriptions for
each uh sort of stage right each sample
stage we have three transcriptors so at
the same well we'll analyze what genes
are expressed not differentially
dramatically changed at a different
stage okay you may Wonder okay then
what's the difference actually with the
previous I you mentioned the Denise's
analyze of course Denise's analyzes the
sense in just the several genes this is
a whole genome analyze but this analysis
per se wouldn't reveal really molecular
mechanisms okay so I will get back to
this latest
talk
so we find the doses called another
actually terminal is similar to
differentially muscle relaxant EMR
uh there's another terminology called
differentially expressed Gene degs okay
so expressing with this stage but not in
that stage a vice versa download grade
operating okay so those comparison you
can see certain messages expressed in
this stage but not in this stage vice
versa okay so you will be able to find
those genes dramatically expression
provider changes so you can see here
this is a real stage upper regulating
you know various comparison you will see
the different differentially expressed
Gene profiles okay so you can see here
just dramatically you know those huge
number nine thousand you know this is a
really huge number okay we did find
those numbers actually a huge number of
links so what matters why you do this
when it's you know really difficult to
study actually how many genes how do you
know which Gene is responsible for that
phenotype I showed previous
okay so uh
so if we're further actually you know
sort of analyze first of all we need to
get rid of some of the most unlikely
involved the ignorance functions right
so first of all compare with this one so
you will see actually only you know
where we need to consider only one one
so 1600 genes about this one so at least
we could get rid of uh 600 genes
scheduling alphabets we don't have to
consider about those genes okay and
similarly
you know this is a down regulatory you
know sort of 2000 nearly 2000 would get
rid of 500 more than 500 genes
and
so on so forth so we get rid of once all
the nearly one sorted and more than one
thousand genes so only need to consider
small number of genes
okay so no the small amount of genes
were already cut to this one similarly
as for that previous slides was 22 28
degrees but for this for about uh
primordial to for all about sexual
development is this could be this kind
of set of genes that's a red that's blue
color actually so it's a it's hard to
interpret why we consider that you know
after the seminar because of time I work
I could work if you want I could explain
why we focus on this
genes
okay so back to this one
now you have zero have with Association
of weight previously we have BMR so
differentially muscle relaxing right and
we have this is TG differentially
expressive genes now what are those
genes that also contains DMR origin so
methylate because we know methylation
matters
okay so only those genes differential
methodology Gene with differentially
maculated region expressed genes with
different muscle rigid most likely that
matters okay so we'll work on this one
no but you can see here still there are
sort of 318 genes and Hyper masculated
18 and very similarly to this G so still
you know that immediate question is
for this stage we will have so many
genes 380 and 200 so it's still about
more than 500 it's very difficult to
study actually not for 23 degree uh we
have about you know nearly 400 genes
hypermesellated and Hyper muscle it now
the immediate question is
hyper-mesylated matters or hypo
methylated matters that's the first
question okay no the methylation of
course where I just recall I showed you
the data DNM isolation inhibitor really
actually eliminates those DNA inherited
macellation inhibitor of course in
inherited young methylation that means
if not DNA democellation that means
supposed to be highly hyper muscle it
right so then therefore actually the
answer to the previous slides is that is
hyper
DMR matters okay not a not a
not the hypo yeah so but hypo mesellated
matters now another question is
we have
no so therefore it matters right so
another question is whether upper
regulatory matters or down regulation
matters
right because immediately you will ask
well for this I am stage required for
this is the upper regulator or down
regulatory matters
no holding and methylation affects GX
ratio so generally speaking oh geez
I should have slides here why didn't
show up
huh
okay here you go so you see actually
generally speaking that the DNA
masturbation affected gene expression
what does that it's a transgression
Factor we know actually binding to the
promoter region and activate the gene
expression that's General uh sort of
lure and however if we just promoter
region that's DNA macellation here that
prevent transcription factor from
binding to this this element then of
course there's no Gene transcription
okay so you know what's the DNA
macellation in hips actually a
suppressed gene expression okay so
therefore actually uh to you know
another example actually down regression
really matters another example is that
uh perhaps you guys already know oh why
this one sure okay
this is the doctor gingivano it's a
publication I believe it's a nature by
technology and you can see here this
actually lame binding proteins rain
binding protein binding to this ranging
scale during immaculation and in the
wild type DNA methylation is less so
than actual range range transcription
factors are gamma's transcription Factor
okay we're binding to that and promote
actually ripening but if you have higher
methylation then actually this
transcription Factor ring couldn't bind
to it of course delay slow down the
wiping process so that will really being
immaculation really inhibits or suppress
uh gene expression okay so again sound
regulated EEG matters okay so back to
this one
okay down regulatory models instead of
this operator similarly to here okay
download glitching mothers so you know
what's
done now to 232 genes that potentially
be responsible or required in order for
IM
develop into
FB stage or actor FP stage okay so on so
forth and
168 genes that is required in order for
uh FB continue developing into FB stage
okay makes sense so no it's much easier
now so narrow down
200 and
180 so nearly to around 200 genes
actually so
and so that's what I say actually so
okay
so therefore so we named these genes
named this Gene called the floral
development C-section Gene fcg okay
required either for IM
to transition to foreign to FP
or that's 28 degree or FP to FB state
transition those genes okay respectively
you can see here
all right what are those genes you may
Wonder actually so this G note this is
different Gene of course the biological
processes several components and the
molecular functions you know those
origin go you will see those kind of
analysts so but I would like to show
your attention as to this first line
that's ribosome
biogenesis of energy so okay this is
genes very very important I personally
believe
okay so now this genes actually what are
those genes you can see
um ribosome biogenesis relatives is a
different Gene we are not going to go
over and but it's very very important
I will explain why we're focused on this
this genes are Robertson about sounded
very boring but it's important as a
matter of fact
and similarly for 22 degree actually
that's a fcg is also actually by a sub
ribosome biogenesis abilities okay so
both of those actually you can see very
very predominantly uh uh ex you know
sort of expressed rolladium really
matters you can see here okay
so now this is sort of a robot to know
about Genesis why we care about the
Robinson and biogenesis related genes
and first of all actually this genes are
extremely highly expressed actually in
the the I should emphasize this is the
counterpart Gene of this brokerage okay
in all of those expressed highly in the
Apex should of course yeah okay so I
will move really really fast enough okay
so this is really matters you know our
robersonal biogenesis really matters you
can see here in cancer biology it's very
very important it's a hot area in cancer
developer cancer therapists as a matter
of fact related to cell division
whatever you can imagine of course
there's four parts development related
to safety wishing as well actually okay
and
um
so with you know in plugs you can see
here the temperature there's a sort of
review articles so a lot of someone
relates to temperature stress change and
the cell cycle at rest
and also developmental abnormalities
okay so this is
you know my gut feeling is when the
student analyzes the data I said well
let's focus on this so my gut feeling
sometimes works I better already once
correct I bet this time will be correct
too okay so and uh being in my solution
so one more temperature uh hyper
methylation then low fcg expression
because no expression of this Gene of
course the flower development will be
stopped ceased okay now back to this one
actually is so you will see what whether
the stream vaccination really matters
because you will see the correlation
temperature masculation and fcg
expression during those different stages
okay for just iron required for IM to FP
stage you can see here 28 degrees 22 and
18 you see the expression this is a
methylation pro modulating Mac solution
okay this is a expression level that's
digital expression level not the higher
the lower temperature and the the lower
methylation and the higher the
expression vice versa okay that's all
those genes I just show you three of
none of you know all qualities very well
okay so those data actually can directly
now those genes actually are predicted
to be at this element DNA a
transcription Factor binding to this
okay this is already the state of
bioinformatica USC what kind of genes uh
transcription of DNA me acceleration
here the transcription Factor bind into
this one so different transcription
factor is predicted to binding as
promoter especially that the dolphin
Gene actually domain with one fingers
that's transcription factors very
predominant you can see yeah similarly
doesn't make sense right similarly for
22 degree is the same thing actually so
predicted all those transcriptional
factors so that makes a lot of sense for
this one now you may Wonder actually
whether macellation really matters with
that expression Yes actually we did the
DNA I think the methylation hip to
treatment you will see actually once you
treat with methylation that isolation is
inhibited then this G expression is
really the separation is released so all
those no exact no exception okay so I
just assure you for 22 degree similarly
okay so this is no exception so let's
make a lot of sense actually for this
okay so DNA my solution you know in
capital really matters actually for
those not to summarize
so we just talk about that 16 degree uh
grow at 16 degrees then produce
cauliflower like uh sort of code and the
continue to develop uh FP then FB that's
of uh for all parts actually we are
consuming or and in order for this I am
developed into FP there's a set of Gene
called fcg is required okay for this
Gene to develop into this one and in
order for FP to continue to develop qfp
then there's another sets of fcg I
already mentioned okay to required for
this transition for this one however at
the 28 degree
especially in the promoted rating of fcg
to suppress this gene expression this
Gene is required as I said in order to
develop from IM to FP but this Gene due
to the separation due to the x uh the
DNA oscillation then of course this this
can will be stopped here at the IM stage
all right continue always at us this
stage so similarly
so this is a 22 degree will be very
similar to this one being helped to this
one okay however after if we wish during
a massillation in hepto then you have to
this massillation even at the 28 degree
it doesn't matter they can continue
always produce that way okay so future
directions I just mentioned first
question is a massillation mechanisms
okay what are the mechanisms to to this
because this is important in future once
we identify the DNA a gene that controls
this one we could manipulate The
Knockout decision
at the high temperature they were not
measurable you know they actually can
grow yeah okay
so uh in the the second question
is what are the fcg functions we could
use genome editing to do that and
acknowledgment and this is uh dated all
the work and they contributed equally
and the change even only actually I
really grateful to him actually one
night the pro later my manuscript and
provide the Insight flow actually and
that uh also just for actually fcg name
actually just offered me actually says
well why not do you call fcg okay so
there's a very pressure use for
information
and there's actually uh dollars and
thanks for the media and different
worldwide different Medias and oh that I
just try to advertise for molecular
Horticulture so we're publishing really
high quality papers in molecular hostage
with immediate
impact factor of 5.9 okay
and uh okay so I advertised for ignite
were also ignite I have a startup for
the resilient talk in cooperation uh we
work on a lot of things that are in
future I hope will be able to share with
you guys okay very excited and I'm
that's it I think oh yeah that's it
and a question I will be happy
to answer any question
yeah Jen can you give us an idea of um
how long at these different temperatures
it takes to start getting the
um you know the the change in the
molecular upregulation I mean so you're
running about constant temperatures
right but under climate change which is
your premise here let's happen or
climate change one hot day
you know it's more and more likely to
happen especially in we're growing a lot
of these crops so how long does it take
do we start seeing a phenotypical that's
a good question actually duration we
haven't performed such kind of
experiment yet yeah that's a good
question though
by the persistent uh quota of you know
sort of a high temperature is Not
Unusual to see actually nowadays right
yeah any other questions do we have any
questions from Geneva
yes I see Zach's got his hand up I can't
figure out how to get my hand up but
this time this is Thomas uh
so very nice work so 25 years ago there
were too few genes we only had like five
and then quickly went to five thousand
which made it impossible to really
investigate from the other side so it's
beautiful how you've brought that down
to a tractable number uh
and that really has facilitated project
progress on this question and being able
to do you know the global analysis from
just being too big and saying it's too
much to deal with
so that is it's nice so
you said thank you though actually
that's how you said that kind of
question you said yeah so back in back
in the day
um it was all about the expression of
the gene called cauliflower and
I wonder if you took an extra look at at
that particular Gene
um to see whether
um it was playing a role in this um
to go back to this that's very good
question actually I'm I mean to say that
actually because you can predict it
based on a Model those teaching a set of
sort of fcg genes will be really
suppressed and uh in the peripheral or
plants right
so it's easy to test as a matter of fact
yeah and we we keep coming back to it
probably only matters occasionally and
not in in this particular genetic system
uh-huh
but this the story keeps recurring so
you have to come back it's such a
beautiful Simple Story just doesn't
happen to be a correct story yo thank
you Thomas but I personally believe
actually this mechanism is conserved as
much yeah or other crops as well yeah
no exactly it's I mean this is this is
such a great system to study it in
because it really separates things out
in time developmentally and the tissues
are relatively large so
Horticulture gives good model systems
that's a good thing do we have any other
questions yeah in the back
um are the methylation blockers
something that r or you think could be
used in the field to Cloud make the
crops more resilient uh you mean that
you have to
no actually because actually this is
five that's chemical five zero three
actually is uh uh used for pencil uh a
therapy actually it's toxic as matter of
fact to inhibit you know vacillation I
showed you a tensor right some hyper
mesolated this inhibitor actually used
to to suppress this uh sort of uh
suppression to reverse the separation
that's another part of that uh cancer
chemotherapest manufacture yeah it's
toxic yeah
okay well let's give um yeah thank you
thank you yeah been at home are you guys
should have my email address for the
email me or stop by 140 uh Amazon
okay especially if you're interesting
ignite failure uh we're we're paid
actually you know worker interesting uh
entrepreneurship uh please contact me
okay yeah thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu